[Music]
[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my 19th episode of dirty
chess tricks against sicilian
in this episode i am going to show you a
beautiful tricky line
against queen b6 rosolimo from the white
perspective
the critical position arises after the
following
opening more order e4
c5 knight to f3 knight to c6
and now bishop to b5 rosolimo
on the board here black has various
responses
and amongst them we are going to look at
one of the trendy move
queen to b6 which not only attacking the
bishop
but the big point is if white take the
knight
then black will recapture with the queen
and that way
he avoid the double pawn
okay no issues we are going to continue
with
knight to c3 and we have reached to the
critical position
well once again black has various
choices as i highlighted over here
but by far the second most popular
choice by the black camp
is to play knight to d4 which is in fact
as per the online database played in
more than 50 games
this move looks very logical not only
black is
attacking our bishop so that if you move
the bishop
then white is losing the time in the
opening
and apart from it the big point is if
white foolishly take this knight
then after c captures d4 two of the
white pieces
are hanging
well believe it or not but this is
exactly
i'm going to recommend because white has
a very sneaky move in this position
namely knight to d5
black has few choices but he really
don't want to play queen to e5
and give white another tempo with b4 and
there is an
old trick that if black foolishly take
this bishop
then after knight to c7 check black
sweetie
is a goner so those two options
are right out of the equation that means
black has to play
queen to d8 and although
at first sight white pieces looks
impressive
it is just matter of time as black is
going to kick them out
and gain time in the opening
and yes indeed that may be the case in
other opening
but not here as white has a
super star move in this position
queen to h5 and the tricky platform
sets right here guys
as happened in many games let's check
out
what happens if black plays some of the
natural moves such as
a6 e6 and even g6
trying to kick our pieces
the first move i want to consider is a6
which is in fact a choice of 2300 plus
rated opponent
against a grand master but i think
he will never forget this trick in his
life after white plays the obvious move
which we are going to play against all
of these responses
did you spot it yup queen to e5
threatening knight to c7 jack and black
would love to play d6 but in fact he
cannot
as this pawn is pinned down
in the game black played the obvious
move f6
giving his king a escape route
white indeed continue with knight to c7
check
and after king to f7 okay
black thought that white can't take the
rook as his queen is hanging
but just one move queen to d5
and believe it or not but black player
resign at just 10th move
of the game well
you may be wondering why as black has
few options
but either black plays the move king to
g6 or e6
both can be met with the same answer
e6 and let me show you the deciding blow
knight captures e6 getting ready for the
discover check
and don't forget this deep on is a
complete pin down
a sample baseline can goes as follows
queen to b6 attacking two of the pieces
well no issues white can continue with
his
king hunt policy knight to g5 check
if king to g6 then queen to f5 is a very
strong reply
so accordingly king has to go on the e
file
afterwards we have this straightforward
sequence
queen check king to d8 queen captures f8
jack
king to c7 and now the simple move in
the world
queen captures g7
well we have the few exchanges pawn
takes g5
queen takes rook pawn takes b5
and after queen captures g8 the dust is
clear
and you can easily see white emerged
with an extra rook and two point
advantage
where on top of everything black king
has been completely misplaced
the second move i want to consider is g6
which is obviously very bad as you know
now what to do
yup queen to e5 double threat
and once again the only route to get out
of this mess
is to play f6 but after that
yup you guessed it knight to c7 check
king to f7 and lovely queen to d5 check
if king to g7 then we have knight to e6
and grabbing the black sweetie so that's
right out of the equation and the movie
6
we know how to deal it right
knight catches e6 get ready for the
discover check
and no matter however black plays this
is
a completely lost position
let's say queen goes to anywhere queen
to b6
and maybe white has another good
sequence but i found this
straightforward response
knight to c7 king to e7
and after knight captures eight once
again
we obtain the whole rook and upon
the third move i want to consider is e6
which will be again met with our strong
queen to e5 idea and it's very funny
that how the spawns are pinned down by
white pieces
and he's completely helpless against
knight to c7 chad
what else we have f6
and now indeed you can continue with
knight to c7
but white has a better move namely
queen captures e6
if bishop to e7 then we have queen to g4
a strong reply
so accordingly the base reply in this
position is
knight g2 e7 but after that
white assault continue with this very
attacking move
e5 trying to open up
the position so there is no way black
can allow this
and f5 is a best reply
but even after this black is not out of
the wood
as white has this dazzling knight
sacrifice
knight to f6 jack which by force
giving white a completely winning age
pawn takes f6 e takes f6
well black should move the queen and
give up the piece
but as happened in many of these cases
one of the game from the database
continue with asics
completely missing the head shot with
f7 a picturesque checkmate
last but not least you should also know
what to do
against the moon knight to f6 as
after this move i think white gate a
slight
opening advantage with the following
sequence
knight captures f6 black has to capture
with the jeep on
because if you continue with capturing
with the e pawn
then he has this positional weaknesses
double
d pawn okay
g captures f6 now you play
bishop to c4 trying to checkmate black
on f7
so once again black needs to parry with
the move
e6 and after the move castle
chess engine seriously liking the white
position
as not only he has a superior peace
development but black has some horrible
pawn structure on the king's side
and all in all i think with some careful
play it is only white
who is having all the fun in this line
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile tricky line in the queen b6
rosalimo
remember meet the moon knight to d4 by
capturing this knight
and then plonk your knight on this juicy
d5 square
so that once black played the move queen
to d8
we have this star move queen to h5
and no matter however black plays
it is only white who is all set
to get the full point
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe
and comment and i will meet you in my
next episode
very soon bye and take care